without question old town is the oldest
wealthiest and greatest city in westeros
though king's landing is more populous
and arguably more powerful
the city straddles the mouth of the
honeywine river and the bounty of the
entire reach flows beneath its great
stone bridges to ports that are renowned
throughout the world thus we needn't
speak more of them more interesting is
the history of the city for none can say
when it was founded many centuries ago a
few bold maesters sought out the
children of the forest who claimed that
men have lived at the mouth of the honey
wine since the dawn age nonsense
mr jelico proved that the city began as
a trading post where ships from valyria
old geese and the summer isles put in to
replenish their provisions and make
repairs
hence the most famous feature of the
city the high tower
raised even before the city walls as a
beacon through the fog covered waters
originally built of wood and standing a
mere 50 feet above the ancient fortress
of his foundation
it is now a thick stone and rises even
taller than the wall
those born and raised in old town can
tell the time of day by where its shadow
falls
but no maester can tell why even in our
oldest records the island on which it
stands is called battle aisle
what battle was fought there
and when
as for the ancient fortress that forms
the tower's base
its walls and interiors are all of solid
black stone with no hints of joins
or mortar and no chisel marks of any
kind
we know it predates the tower itself by
thousands of years
but who built it how
and against what
the maesters who have studied it
declared it to be a valyrian
construction
akin to dragonstone and the black walls
of volantis
as is well known the dragon lords of
valyria could turn stone to liquid with
dragonflame to shape as they wished
didn't one archmaester link the fortress
to the vanished maze makers of laura
and another maester to the legendary
deep ones who inhabited the iron islands
before the ironborn
oh both marginal opinions without common
support
but of more importance than the origin
of the tower
is the family to which it gave its name
house hightower
the ancient ruling family of old town
known for their prudence and love of
peace and pieces of gold
during the age of heroes when lyman
hightower saw the gardener kings
conquering the reach
he didn't beat them on the battlefield
but in the god's wood
he bound his house to theirs by marriage
and transformed house hightower from
wealthy but relatively minor kings to
the greatest lords of the rich
thanks to lord lymon's foresight
highgarden has always defended old town
allowing the high towers to focus on
higher pursuits such as learning and
trade
on that we agree
when the andals invaded westeros lord
dorian hightower told his wife of 20
years
that wars are bad for trade
and to make his point traded her for a
young andel princess
when aegon the conqueror was earning his
name
house hightower traded its loyalty to
the gardeners for his confirmation of
their rights
welcoming him with open arms and open
gates
house hightower bent the knee to aegon
to spare the city from his dragons
i would think such insinuations and
insults beneath even you qyburn
and again mockery of one's bitters is
the trade of fools
i wouldn't know
perhaps if i'd studied at the citadel as
long as you grand maester
the citadel is the greatest seat of
learning in the known world
without it and the mace as it trains
westeros would be a land of superstition
and ignorance
like the ignorance that shrouds the
citadel's own birth
even without records we have more than
enough reason to believe that the
citadel began as a court of scholars and
priests
assembled by a second son of house
hightower
when he died his elder brother raised
the citadel so that wise men would
always have a home in westeros
and could continue the inquiries and
debates that had given such joy to his
younger brother
his little brother's pets
as legend has it he called them and so
the maesters have remained only their
masters have changed
now they serve every lord with a castle
for a fee of course
whilst the citadel serves its own
importance
every word you speak merely validates
your own expulsion from our ranks
knowledge is validation enough
i assumed the world's greatest minds
would agree and perhaps they would if
i'd met them old town is a city for old
men and old beliefs
the citadel of old town is the greatest
center of learning in the world
not that it has much competition really
most lords think of books the way they
think of younger sons
useful to have around as long as they
keep to the corners
back when house hightower still ruled
old town as kings a crippled younger son
sought solace in books and those who
wrote them and became the greatest
patron of learning in his day
scholars of all sorts flocked to old
town to debate and write and
debate
after this prince peramor's death his
brother granted land to paramore's pets
as the wise men were called though now
they're known as maesters
mud men
bog devils
those are just the most pleasant names
our fellow northerners have for us
the crannogmen who live in the swamps of
the neck
because we do not live in castles like
them
because we do not farm like them because
we are not tall or rich like them
but through our veins flows the same
blood of the first men
and at times
maybe something more
we still live much as they did on
floating islands in houses of thatch and
woven reeds
we fish hunt and tell our children of
our heroes
the knight of the laughing tree who
fought in the year of the full spring
the last marsh king who challenged the
starks and lost his crown and his
daughter
and other stories older still since lost
to the world
the neck was not always a swamp
in the dawn age it was as dry and
fertile as the rest of the north
but during the war with the first men
the children of the forest brought down
the hammer of waters on the neck trying
to break westeros in two
when the waters finally receded they
left the bogs and swamps we know today
many of the first men decided to fight
on but my ancestors wisely chose to heed
the children's power and advance no
farther
they beat their swords into frog spears
and fish hooks and settle the land
forever devastated by the folly of war
unlike the rest of westeros we keep no
garrisons and raise no soldiers for
petty's fats with our neighbors
our land protects its own
an outsider will find in the neck an
endless morass of suck holes quick sands
and green grass that looks solid to the
unwary eye but turns to water the
instant you tread on it
if you're lucky enough to be armored
you'll only drown inside your own steel
if you're not
you get to meet what swims in that water
serpents and monstrous lizard lions with
teeth like daggers are never enough to
eat
don't worry
only your horse will live long enough to
feel their poisons burning through it
if you somehow survive all this
you may find that a well-placed dart can
be as deadly as any blade
not that you'll see us blowing it your
way
since the fall of the last marsh king
house reed has ruled the neck beneath
the banner of a black lizard lion on a
grey green field
we are not wealthy powerful or known
even to our own countrymen
our home grey water watch is no castle
you've ever seen
and seeing it once does not mean you'll
ever find it again
for grey water watch moves
many would-be conquerors have died
trying to find us
with war all around and our stark lord
besieged on all sides many more will
doubtless soon try
they will look at us on a map and see a
stranglehold for the north
and they will forget that the sea itself
once entered the neck
and not all of it returned
our land stretches from the wall down to
the neck a narrow land that devises from
the rest of westeros
legend has it that the children of the
forest flooded it in their war against
the first men
if that's true
every northman owes them a debt of
gratitude
the swamps of the neck are as good as
the wall for keeping out unwelcome
armies and if the swamps don't deter you
the chronic men should
small shy people who rarely leave those
swamps and who follow house reed the
gatekeepers of the north and among the
most important and loyal bannermen of
house stark
also a bit strange
i heard their author felt he once is a
child
it's like no other lords
ancient and dark
they swear by earth and water
by bronze and iron
and by ice
and fire